- These are not necessarily
places I'm going to recommend,
but if you find yourself there,
you gotta eat.
(mariachi music)
Today we've taken a look at five
Mexican fast food restaurants,
and we're trying to find the
healthiest options for you
if these are the places
that you find yourself at.
First up we're looking at Taco Bell.
One of the things I liked
about Taco Bell is that they're
up front with their ingredients,
and I saw they had like a healthy menu.
When they have those,
go for them.
So I did the Cantina Power Bowl,
I don't care for cheese,
so I take off the cheese,
(electronic buzz)
but I'm gonna add in their salsa,
but not their regular salsa,
(electronic buzz)
the salsa that has the pico de gallo,
because it has less sodium in it.
I did not do the guacamole.
It wasn't worth it, I'd rather
just eat an avocado later.
So next up we had Del Taco.
I,
uh, don't really have
anything I would get at
Del Taco.
(electronic buzz)
So if you're gonna go to Del
Taco this is what I would say:
get, get what you want.
It's not gonna be that good for you.
(sigh) Chipotle.
I always think you're so healthy.
I was shocked
at the amount of fat.
We're talking
two days worth of fat.
Don't even go into the tacos,
or the burritos, just don't even.
I would get the burrito bowl.
Black beans or rice.
I would get the chicken, and I would get
pico de gallo with it,
and I would get the fajita veggies.
No cheese.
(electronic buzz)
No guacamole.
Sorry.
I have to say, I was surprised.
It actually had some really good options.
The one that I would get
is the classical salad.
You can get it with or without chicken,
it doesn't change it too
much in terms of fat.
I wouldn't get it with the cheese--
(electronic buzz)
but know if you do get it with the cheese
it brings up the fat, the saturated fat
in particular.
And then I would actually
get the dressing on the side,
an avocado salsa.
I've eaten at Baja Fresh.
I like the sound of the name,
it's fresh,
I think they're gonna have
fresh ingredients there.
I was surprised at how
many calories are in
some of the salads.
So the one that I picked was
the Baja Barbecue Chicken Salad.
I put the dressing on it.
And even with the dressing it's not
too bad in terms of calories.
If they offer fresh avocado
I would put that on there.
But I wouldn't do the guacamole.
The biggest surprise for me with Baja
was that all their tostada salads
are over 1000 calories.
If I'm gonna eat 1000
calories for a salad,
I'm going all out for a burrito
that has the works
with all kinds of sour
cream and guacamole,
and I'm just gonna forget.
So here are my top three ways
that you can eat healthier.
First, number one,
don't order off the menu.
So have an idea of what
you want before you go in,
and then try to add some
healthy things to it.
So number two is, have your
sauces and your dressings
on the side.
Get it on the side, put a little
bit on or dip your fork in,
or dip your food in,
and just eat a little bit of it.
That will save calories.
And number three is,
whenever you can add vegetables,
go for it.
That's going to bulk things up,
it's gonna give you more fiber,
more vitamins and minerals,
and you won't have to
eat as many of the tacos
or the burritos or the other options,
because you'll be more full on
roughage.
(piano melody)